bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous ai
réservé un guide d'achat pour acheter
votre smartphone moins cher alors pas
forcément pour vous dire quel téléphone
htc pas du tout le propos
le propos c'est de vous dire où acheter
votre téléphone moins cher comment faire
et comment économiser l'argent on y va
[Musique]
les téléphones aujourd'hui coûte
extrêmement cher les prix ou plutôt
tendance à monter kbc et au final qui
c'est qui paye l'addition c'est vous
dans cette vidéo ce que je vais faire
parce que tout simplement vous donnez 10
bonnes astuces pour payer votre
téléphone moins cher et économiser de
l'argent
alors il ya des astuces que je pense
vous connaissez déjà il y en a d'autres
que vous ne connaissez peut-être pas il
a peut-être que vous connaissez une vie
auquel vous avez pas pensé
donc on va regarder ça ensemble et on va
commencer tout de suite par la numéro 1
la toute première astuce concerne les
produits reconditionnés ce qu'on appelle
le refurb qu'est ce que le refurb via ce
sont des produits reconditionnés ou des
produits d'occasion que des grandes
marques ont récupéré ont vérifié en
remis en état et vous garantissent
pendant un temps alors aujourd'hui il ya
pas mal de sites qui font du refurb y en
a des très connu il y en a des moins
connus celui qui s'est lancé il ya pas
longtemps ses amazones d'ailleurs je
vous ai mis un lien dans la description
pour aller voir
il ya également la fnac également un
gain de la description qui fait aussi
des produits reconditionnés apple le
fait aussi sur son site directement par
contre ils le font uniquement sur les
mac les ipad les ipod et les apple tv
pour l'instant sur les iphone j'ai rien
vu mais concernant les autres produits
c'est vraiment intéressant
d'ailleurs vous en avait déjà parlé dans
une précédente vidéo lorsque je donnais
des conseils d'achat pour acheter votre
mac dans des conditions intéressantes pu
savoir quel mac choisir la vidéo est ici
je vous invite à aller la voir
et d'ailleurs vous allez voir le refurb
d'apple est plutôt pas mal donc pour
l'instant je vais pas vous parler
d'apple sans reefer parce que il ne
reconditionne pas les iphone mais plutôt
amazon la fnac où tout est quanti alors
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
vous avez vraiment des produits qu'ils
ont vécu mais qui sont bonnes qualités
au monde et surtout fonctionne en gros
si vous voulez c'est de l'occasion
garantie durs vendus par un
professionnel
donc au moins vous êtes tranquille et
maintenant ça nous amène à la deuxième
astuces ou deuxième conseil comme vous
voulez c'est l'occasion non garantis
c'est à dire acheter un produit
d'occasion auprès d'un particulier donc
un produit qui a également déjà vécue
par contre vous êtes pas du tout sûr de
l'état et ça ça peut tout su être
beaucoup plus embêtant
il existe bien évidemment beaucoup de
site leboncoin en tête le bon coin avec
ces arnaqueurs c'est un site qui est
très sérieux et je ne suis pas le bon
coin mais par contre c'est un peu comme
si un site où il ya énormément de
produits et qui cartonne
il y a beaucoup de
là dessus il faut faire super super
attention donc justement et quelques
astuces pour pas se faire arnaquer que
vous achetiez sur ebay leboncoin ou
alors d'autres sites des journaux
pourquoi pas le faire à l'ancienne dans
un vieux canard local une annonce
quelqu'un qui vend son smartphone il
faut faire des vérifications alors déjà
vérifié l'état lorsque vous aurez le
téléphone dans les mains vous rencontrer
la personne pouvoir vérifier s'ils
fonctionnent
pourquoi pas faire une vidéo skype avec
lui qui vous montrera que son téléphone
marche encore il faut vraiment vérifié
l'état avant de le faire par
correspondance parce qu'on peut
rapidement se faire arnaquer il ya un
autre mot qui est super intéressant
c'est de vérifier que téléphone n'a pas
été volé parce que si téléphone été volé
et que vous l'achetez vous devenez de
fait en recéleurs et là vous pouvez
encourir des problèmes alors ce qu'il
faut faire c'est vérifier le code imei
ce que vous fait vous demander à la
personne qui le vent qui vous donne le
code imei
alors pour l'avoir c'est facile il
suffit de faire étoiles 10h06 diez et
vous avez votre code qui s'affiche sur
votre téléphone
ce que vous faites quoi vous avez ce
code vous allez sur un site dédié et
vous rentrez le code dedans et vous
vérifier si le téléphone n'a pas été
déclarée soient perdus soit volé alors
les sites aujourd'hui qui montre ce
service sont des services qui sont
payants il ya un site qui m'a l'air très
sérieux qui s'appelle veritas tirer
certification points comme je vous mets
le lien dans la description
j'ai noté les prix si je regarde pour un
smartphone classique un classique
or apple en gros si vous voulez parce
que apple suite ça serait beaucoup plus
cher on est à 2 euros 80 pour une
vérification du mei est à 3 ans soixante
dix pour un smartphone d'apple alors ça
c'est pas là pour tous les produits y
reçoit des mac
que ce soit des tables est que ce soit
autre chose mais sa mine de rien c'est
super important de le faire parce que si
vous êtes recéleurs vous risquez bien
évidemment cinq ans de prison et 305 et
375000 euros damende le troisième point
et non des moindres celle achetée par
son opérateur alors là je vous arrête
tout de suite il ya plein de gens qui
nous disent moi mais moi je les payais
pas chercher la clé par mon opérateur je
les payais les cinq cents euros je les
payais 400 euros j'ai payé en euros je
les payais pas cher sauf que en réalité
le téléphone vous le payez vous de payer
le prix fort et des fois vous parie même
plus cher parce que c'est un petit
crédit qu'on vous fait alors j'ai pris
un exemple j'ai ma feuille là et je vous
le détailler
vous allez tout de suite comprendre
alors imaginons qu'on veuille acheter un
iphone 10 alors un iphone 10 il est
vendu par apple que je vous dise pas de
bêtises 1159 euros pour le modèle en 64
giga choisissons le site de sfr et je
vous dis
l'offre que j'ai trouvé vous achetez
votre iphone avec forfait 4 169,99 euros
en plus il faut rajouter une 24 24
mensualités de 8 euros ce qui fait que
quand tout vous le payez vous ne serait
ce que pour le téléphone 661 euros avec
99 centimes jusque là vous me suivez
en plus il faut rajouter le coût du
forfait c'est là qu'on se marre je vous
ai pris le forfait qui me permettait
effectivement mène le pays à 4 69 cents
donc c'est un forfait qui à 45 euros par
mois pendant 12 mois et ensuite la
deuxième année vous payez 60 euros par
mois pendant 12 mois sur un engagement
de 24 mois ça va vous coûter 780 euros
va forfait donc vous avez votre
téléphone à 661 99 plus 780 euros de
forfait
ça vous ramène quand même l'ensemble à
1441 99 alors effectivement que dans
vous avez un forfait tout illimité sms
mms illimités
il ya des forfaits des griffes les vous
avez des forfaits tout inclus je prends
par exemple pour rester chez sfr vous
approchez pas de plus pour sfr mais
c'est un exemple les gens qui en prend
d'autres mais j'ai pris sur lui la
excusez moi si c'est pas le meilleur
exemple c'est un exemple vous avez par
exemple chez red de sfr des forfaits à
moins de 20 euros par mois
il vous calculé que si vous achetez
votre iphone nu à 1159 euros plus les 20
euros par mois pendant 24 mois vous êtes
en réalité kif kif bourricot à quelques
euros au niveau du tarif par rapport à
ce que vous allez payer avec l'offre de
chez sfr avec le téléphone lac à 169
euros
tout ça pour dire que en réalité votre
téléphone vous ne payez pas du tout
moins cher donc pour moi achetés via son
opérateur
ça revient à acheter son téléphone avec
cris ça nous emmène tout ça au quatrième
point parce que pour moi le troisième
point c'est pas une affaire mais il
fallait en parler
le quatrième point s'est acheté un
nouveau smartphone juste après la sortie
de son successeur
on va prendre l'exemple par exemple du
samsung galaxy s suite où elle suit plus
qui sont des modèles du début d'année
2010 est en 2018 sort le samsung galaxy
s 9 et s9 plus alors c'est l'exemple
mais c'est valable pour beaucoup
d'autres produits chez samsung c'est
intéressant mais je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
parce que lorsque le produit est sorti
forcément la version antérieure le
modèle de l'année d'avant va forcément
baisser alors c'est un peu moins breschi
apple parce qu'il ya quand même une
politique de prix assez élevé même sur
les produits vie dure et de génération
antérieure
par contre c'est samsung lorsque vous
achetez un produit à prendre l'exemple
du galaxy et suite
accès suite est sortie mars si je dis
pas de bêtises mars avril 2010 est à peu
près à vue n'ait excusez moi si je suis
pas très précis quelques mois après il a
vraiment baissé mais assez
significativement et si vous achetez un
samsung galaxy s suit alors que le s9
ait annoncé ou encore pire que le s9 est
sorti vous allez voir vous êtes payé
beaucoup moins cher mais vraiment
beaucoup moins cher pour avoir quasiment
les mêmes technologies pour trouver de
chez son successeur alors à moins
d'avoir vraiment un produit
révolutionnaire qui munich l'accord est
comme un galaxy x qui pourrait sortir
ou alors comme un iphone disque est
sorti par rapport à l'iphone 8 voix
encore mieux à l'iphone 5 mais sinon ça
vaut pas vraiment coup donc vous le
paierez beaucoup moins cher d'avoir un
téléphone qui est un téléphone premium
vraiment haut de gamme sur la génération
d'avant
comment mène directement à mon cinquième
point qu' un petit peu je dirais la
suite du quatrième point c'est acheter
son téléphone à la bonne date
alors effectivement après le modèle
suivant qui vient de sortir mais
également l'acheter
par exemple après le mwc alors le mwcc
quoi si vous connaissez pas c'est le
mobile world congress c'est un peu la
grande messe de la téléphonie mobile si
vous voulez qui a lieu fin février début
mars de chaque année est assez souvent
on constate que les prix après le mobile
world congress mwc baisse donc ça peut
être un moment intéressant un moment à
guetter si vous voulez acheter votre
smartphone aux alentours du mois de mars
lévriers mars attendez que le mwc soit
passé et regarder s'il ya une petite
chute de prix c'est intéressant
autre moment très intéressant c est la
fin de l'année le quatrième jeudi du
mois de novembre
vous avez le black friday suivi le lundi
d'après du cybermonday ou là
effectivement les prix ont tendance à
chuter et vous allez faire des vraies
affaires
et vous allez pouvoir acheter un
smartphone beaucoup moins cher et ça
croyez moi c'est super intéressant
16e point les comparateurs de prix alors
effectivement vous allez acheter un
produit neuf vous risquez de le payer
cher mais par contre il se peut qu'ils
aient un vendeur qui fasse une promotion
sur un produit et ça peut être très
intéressant je vous invite à les dents
vous
ou un autre de votre recherche vous
tapez comparateurs de prix et vous
recherchez le nom de votre smartphone du
promeneur tout cas qui vous intéresse et
vous regardez s'il n'y a pas une petite
différence vous allez économiser
quelques euros alors ce sera forcément
un truc monstrueux mais tout est bon à
prendre
septième point acheter un mobile chinois
qui n'est pas encore sorti en france ou
qui ne sortira jamais en france car
beaucoup de fabricants chinois zao mis
en tête de liste qui ne commercialise
pas tous leurs produits en france et
vous pourriez faire de vraies affaires
là dessus ça c'est super intéressant ce
que je vous invite moi c'est d'aller
regarder sur différents sites internet
chinois
même sur la fnac par exemple pourquoi
pas il y en a d'autres mais qui vont
tout simplement vous proposer des
produits chinois importés de chine
et vous allez pouvoir les toucher
beaucoup moins cher sur des technologies
qui sont en tout cas très intéressante
mais qui sont vraiment en concurrence
par rapport à ce que vous avez sur les
produits premium milieu de gamme donc ça
c'est vraiment des choses à surveiller
attention par contre où vous l'acheter
parce qu'il faut que les frais de douane
soit payée parce qu'une fois arrivée
votre produit à la douane si les
contrôler et s'il n'y a pas une vraie
douanes de régler terre cabade petit
bordereau à l'intérieur mais il se peut
que votre produit reste coincé à la
frontière et que vous vous gagnez rien
qui me répondent récupérer alors
justement puisqu'on parle de frontières
ça nous emmène au huitième point le
huitième point qui est super intéressant
s'il pense qu'il faut savoir que les
téléphones sont pas au même prix dans
tous les pays si vous avez un projet
d'acheter un téléphone et que vous allez
voyager dans les temps à venir jeter un
petit coup d'oeil
je vous prends un exemple tout bête on
va parler justement comme l'iphone 10
alors pourquoi pas soit c'est un produit
quand même cher et c'est très
intéressant vous allez voir on leur
parle toujours de 64 giga vendus par
apple aux états unis il coûte 999
dollars en france il est vendu mule 1159
euros alors 999 dollars il faut savoir
ça fait 8 142 euros
842 euros aux états unis 1159 euros en
france il ya quand même quasiment 200
euros d'écart donc si vous voulez si
vous avez en projet d'aller aux états
unis et que vous voulez acheter un
iphone 10 achetés le directement là bas
alors attention une fois de plus vous ne
paierez pas les frais de douane lorsque
vous allez acheter un produit de cette
valeur la barre avec vous le ramener en
france
ce que je vous conseille et vous enlevez
tout l'emballage vous ne dormez pas
l'emballage vous mettez votre carte sim
le téléphone dans la poche ni vu ni
connu
on arrive maintenant au neuvième point
recyclez votre ancien smartphone alors
effectivement ça va pas vous permettre
d'économiser sur l'achat mais en tout
cas vous allez déjà avoir un petit
pécule une petite cagnotte pour pouvoir
investir
ça c'est intéressant parce que
s'accumuler avec les autres astuces mais
au final vous allez vraiment vous y
retrouver alors ce que je vous conseille
lorsque vous avez des vieux smartphone
vous en faites rien vous voulez pas
garder on téléphone de secours
est ce que vous voyez contraire c'est
gagner un petit peu d'argent de plus
pour pouvoir financer le nouveau
smartphone qui est des sites qui font du
rachat et qui font du recyclage qui ont
pas voulu reprendre dont vous allez
pouvoir monétiser votre ancien
smartphone
je vous invite à rechercher dans google
rachat de smartphones et vous allez voir
que toute une liste qui va s'afficher
devant vous après vous en tirer
davantage d'argent
vous vous en doutez si le produit est en
bon état forcément six ligas et il
voudra pas grand chose maintenant on va
garder pas le meilleur pour la fin mais
presque c'est la dixième astuces
ce sont les sites de cashback je sais
pas si le système de cashback ça vous
parle je me rapproche un peu parce que
la chaîne veut rentrer un peu dans
l'intimité les sites de cashback 6 et
quoi ressemble à [ __ ] qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un site de cashback un site de
cashback ce tout simplement un site dans
lequel vous allez passer pour acheter
chez un marchand quelconque et le site
de cashback lui un lien d'affiliation il
a touché une commission
cette commission il va vouloir revenir
il va vouloir reverser soir en forme de
bons d'achat soit en forme de
commissions directement et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que si vous avez
acheté pas non plus un smartphone qui
coûte quand même une petite somme
et bien vous allez pouvoir récupérer un
peu d'argent dessus alors pas forcément
de l'argent directement disponibles sur
votre compte
un instant t mais pourquoi pas du bon
d'achat pour plus tard si vous avez des
cadeaux des choses à prévoir ça peut
être vraiment très intéressant les sites
de cashback je vous invite pareil allez
dans google vous tapez cashback
smartphone vous allez ont trouvé pas mal
et vous allez voir ça c'est aussi une
bonne astuce
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur toutes ses astuces pour
acheter un smartphone pas cher alors ce
que je vous dis aujourd'hui pour les
smartphones c'est vrai pour les produits
high tech en règle générale toutes ses
astuces pouvait les décliner les adapter
et vous verrez
vous serez gagnant dites moi ce que vous
en pensez est-ce que vous avez
d'ailleurs déjà achetés par des sites de
cashback
est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté du
reconditionnés est ce que vous avez
acheté sur leboncoin ou équivalent
est-ce que vous avez été arnaqués mettez
moi sans commentaire c'est toujours
importante âge et son expérience
je vous remercie d'avoir fait cette
vidéo je vous invite à laisser des
jolies pousse à vous abonner
parce qu'on va faire beaucoup de vidéos
comme celle là pour vous donner des
astuces des techniques pour acheter
mieux acheter acheter moins cher des
astuces aussi pour savoir comment
améliorer votre batterie comment faire
de la photo de meilleure qualité il ya
énormément de choses à venir donc rester
connecté abonnez vous et n'oubliez pas
que d'ici quelques jours je pars au csa
las vegas je vais tout vous raconter sur
la high tech vous montrer les nouveautés
les nouveaux produits les nouvelles
technologies et tutti quanti
merci à vous je vous embrasse soyez
sages portez vous bien fait pas trop de
bêtises et à très bientôt
[Musique]